vamos ahora a intentar aplicar el
teorema stoxx así que aquí tenemos este
pequeño diagrama aquí a la izquierda y
tenemos esta trayectoria la cual vamos a
llamarse y no es otra cosa más que la
intersección de gemma z igualados pero
esta expresión no nos dice mucho
esencialmente lo que tenemos es este
plano déjenme tratar de dibujarlo de
esta forma okay tenemos un plano que va
a atravesar este cuerpo este cuerpo
sólido digamos o esta superficie cuál es
la superficie es x cuadrada massieu
cuadrada igual a 1 es decir tenemos
círculos en cada corte que hagamos en el
eje z
entonces esencialmente es un cilindro es
un cilindro o más bien debería decir un
tubo infinito infinito hacia arriba y
hacia abajo y además nos dan este campo
vectorial
efe definido en la primera componente
como - ye cuadrada en la segunda
componente x y en la tercera se zeta
cuadrada
nos piden calcular la integral de este
campo vectorial a lo largo de esta curva
se ok entonces quién va a ser esto quién
es esencialmente esto bueno pues lo que
vamos a intentar hacer es calcularlo
utilizando el teorema de stocks que es
la integral en la integral sobre toda la
superficie del rotacional del campo
vectorial entonces quién es
quién va a ser esto va a ser la integral
de nuestro rotacional el rotacional del
campo vectorial que me dieron punto n
punto n
punto n que multiplica esta pequeña
diferencial de superficie
eso es esencialmente lo que vamos a
intentar hacer utilizando el teorema de
stocks ahora quién es este vector n
quién es n n pues es el vector normal a
la superficie pero todavía no nos hemos
tomado la superficie la superficie que
nos vamos a tomar es esta es la más
sencilla que podemos utilizar con esta
curva como frontera pues es esta porción
del del plano de esta porción del plano
que está acotado por la curva entonces
voy a tomarme a ese como la porción del
plano
porción del plano
ok esta esta porción del plano que estoy
pintando con verde y que está acotada
acotada por la curva se esta es perdón
por c entonces esta es la superficie que
me voy a considerar para utilizar el
teorema de stocks ahora lo que hay que
hacer es evaluar esta integral y para
hacerlo necesitamos un par de cosas
primero hay que dar la parametrización
de nuestra superficie que en realidad no
debe ser muy difícil ya lo hemos hecho
cuando vimos integrales de superficie y
también hay que calcular el rotacional
df y finalmente evaluar la integral que
la integral doble que nos queda pero
bueno eso lo haremos en próximos vídeos